ترقب دولي لفتح معبرين لادخال المساعده
الى سوريا وفرنسا تهدد بقرار من مجلس
الامن اذا لم يلتزم النظام
تلاشي فرص العثور على ناجين والجهود تتركز
على الايواء ومساعده المتضررين من الزلزال
كيف تعترف بصعوبه الوضع في حلف الاطلسي
يبحث اليوم زياده المساعدات والتدريب
للجيش الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه الساعه الاخباريه تاتيكم من
العربيه اعلنت كل من واشنطن وبرلين انهما
تنتظران تنفيذ النظام السوري قرار فتح
معبرين لمرور المساعدات الانسانيه فقد
اعتبرت الولايات المتحده فتح المعبرين
امرا ايجابيا اذا كان الاسد جديا في
الوعود التي قطعها للامم المتحده وكان
الامين العام للامم المتحده قال ان فتح
المعبرين وكذلك ايضا تسهيل دخول الدعم
الانساني من خلال تسريع اليه الموافقه على
التاشيرات وتسهيل السفر من شانه ان يسمح
بدخول مزيدا من المساعدات بشكل اسرع
كما استقبلت برلين الخبر بشكل ايجابي حيث
صرحت الخارجيه الالمانيه بان قرار النظام
السوري فتح معبرين جديدين للمساعدات هو
خطوه مهمه السفير الفرنسي لدى الامم
المتحده نيكولاس نيكولاس
قال ان انه اذا لم يتم تنفيذ الاتفاق
بشفافيه واستدامه دون عقبات فيجب على مجلس
الامن النظر في اعتماد قرار يسمح بالوصول
امل ان يكون الاسد جدا في هذا الامر لم
تكن روسيا وحدها هي التي عرضت هذا الامر
في الماضي فقد جادل نظام الاسد باستمرار
ضد المزيد من المعابر الانسانيه لكن اذا
كان النظام مجددا في ذلك واذا كان على
استعداد لتطبيق الوعود فسيكون ذلك امرا
جيدا للشعب السوري
سفير سوريا لدى الامم المتحده بسام الصباغ
قال ان دمشق عبرت مرارا وتكرارا عن
التزامها بايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
السوريين اينما كانوا على الاراضي السوريه
وعبر جميع المعابر الممكنه لمده ثلاثه
اشهر
عبر جميع المعابر الممكنه سواء من داخل
سوريا او عبر الحدود لمده ثلاثه اشهر من
اجل ضمان ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
لشعبنا في شمال غرب سوريا
في اديمان التركي
في اليوم الثامن وبعد قليل في اليوم
التاسع اختلفت الصوره والمشهديه وايضا
التقديمات الاساسيه والمساعدات في هذه
المدينه ويبدو الى ان هنالك دفع من قبل
الشركات الخاصه والحكومه التركيه
والجامعات والمنظمات الاهليه الى مزيد من
كل التقنيات الحديثه لعمليه تقديم الاغاثه
هنا في هذه الشركه التي هي مطعم في الاساس
في اسطنبول وفي انقره وعندها عده من
المطاعم قامت اليوم بنصب هذه الخيمه والان
هؤلاء مجموعه من المتطوعين يقومون بطهي
الطعام الذي يوزع مجانا على كل من هو قائم
في هذا المخيم بالاضافه ايضا كما نشاهد
هذا الجزء الثاني من ياتي الى هنا وهذا
المركز يضم ما يقارب ثلاثه الى اربعه الاف
من النازحين في الداخل التركي بالاضافه
الى النازحين السوريين اذا الى هذه
السيارات
طاهر هذه ما هي هي سيارات البث
للتليفونات الذي لا يملك لا يملك هاتفا
خلويا يمكن له ان ياتي الى هناك ثم بعد
ذلك يجري الاتصالات ما يسمى بالخط الارضي
كل ما هو تقني وحديث ومتطور قام المنظومه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه في
تركيا بجزه ودفعه الى الاماكن التي حصل
فيها هنا ايضا يقدمون الشيء الساخن ايضا
ايضا في هذا الخيمه التي سترى فيها يعني
ترى فيها الغرابه او ايضا العشابه من
الامر كيف وصلت الامور في اداره عمليه
المساعدات والتقنيات سنذهب الى هذه الخيمه
وايضا سنرى الان ماذا يجري
نرى
مواطنه تركيه تحمل مجموعه من الخبز هو
الان الساخن سندخل الى الداخل ايضا
ونشاهد ماذا الذي يجري نشاهد الخبز الساخن
كيف يجري ويتم توزيعه مباشره على كل من هو
موجود في المدينه هنا ايضا هذا الطحين هذه
الالات هذه مجموعه من المتطوعين وايضا علم
هذا الفرن ركب على عجل على عجاله او على
عشره من امره كما نشاهد الان الخبز في
الفرن ايضا يخبز ثم بعد ذلك يؤتى الى هنا
معنا لا مشاهدينا من منطقه نورداغ في غازي
عنتابلو مراسله العربيه اهلا بك يا زيدان
معنا صبيحه اليوم التاسع اذا هذا اليوم في
المناطق المنكوبه كيف تبدو الصوره لديك
نعم كما تتابعين يعني نحن في البعض
المناطق التي تمت الانتهاء من رفع او
انتهاء عمليات البحث في هذه المناطق هنا
في نوردا هذه المنطقه
عفوا هذه المنطقه كنا فيها يوم امس في هذا
الموقع بالذات كانت فرق الانقاذ تبحث عن
عالقين تحت الانقاض مع الاسف لم
مع الاسف لم يتمكنوا من العثور على ناجين
انما وصلوا الى بعض الجثث وقاموا برفع
وقاموا بانتشال الجثث وبالتالي انتهت
عمليات البحث في هذا الموقع كما في مواقع
عديده هنا في نوردا وما تزال عمليات البحث
مستمره في بعض المواقع لكن
كما تشاهدين يعني حجم الدمار في هذه
المدينه كبير وكبير جدا هم يعني حتى الان
عمليه ازاله الانقاض لم تبدا من معظم
المواقع كانوا كانت كل جهود منصبه على
عمليات
البحث والانقاذ لكن حتى الان عمليه رفع
الانقاذ لم تبدا في هذه المنطقه في عديد
المواقع حجم الدمار في هذه المدينه كبير
جدا احياء بالكامل انهارت
وعشرات المباني
اصبحت غير صالحه للسكن حتى المباني
السليمه وعددها قليل السلطات ترفض
لاصحابها السماح بالعوده اليها خوفه من
الهزات الارتداديه التي لم تتوقف في غازي
عنتاب الليله الماضيه كان هناك هزه
ارتداديه طبعا
يعني امام هذا الدمار امام حجم هذا الدمار
كل سكان المدينه او كل سكان البلده
حاليا هم في اماكن ايواء مؤقته بما ان
في مثل هذه الكوارث وبعد ان يعني تم انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه من تحت الانقاض الان من
بقي على قيد الحياه بعد هذه الكارثه جهود
الايواء اين وصلت وهل يتم الاستجابه
لاحتياجات الجميع لانه كان هناك الكثير من
القصص لاناس اضطروا لامضاء اكثر من اسبوع
في سيارتهم بعد ان فقدوا منزلهم دون
الحصول على خيمه واحده
نعم بالضبط يعني رغم كل المساعدات التي
وصلت هناك البائع هناك بعض
العائلات لم تتمكن من الحصول على خيم
وطبعا الخيم ليست هي الحل يعني في النهايه
الخيام هي مكان مؤقت لعده ايام من المفترض
ان لا اكثر لان هذه الخيم على سبيل المثال
هذه الخيمه يعني يمكن ان تقي من بروده
الطقس وايضا يمكن ان تكون
لذلك انا اختيار ما بين وخيمه فالخيمه على
الاقل يعني تمثل سقفا فوق رؤوسهم نعم نعم
طبعا طبعا هنا نتحدث عن ادنى مقومات
الحياه بلا شك طبعا نحن تابعتهم على شاشه
العربيه المقابلات التي اجريناها صباح امس
مع اشخاص كما ذكرتي كانوا يبيتون لمده
اسبوع في السياره في السياره وبعضهم ايضا
كان
خرج يناشد يريد خيمه يعني كما تحدثنا رغم
ان غالبيه سكان نورداث الغالبيه العظمى
حصلوا على قيام لكن بعض العائلات لم تتمكن
من الحصول
لذلك يعني المساعدات المستمره نامل ان يتم
حل هذا الموضوع لكن كنت اتحدث عن ان
الخيام ايضا هي ليست الحل لذلك بلديه غازي
عنتاب تعمل الان على بناء
مخيم كبير او ما تسمى مدينه كبيره او مجمع
سكني مكون من كرفانات هذه الكرفانات عباره
عن غرفه
وملحقاتها سيتم نقل قسم كبير من سكان هذه
الخيام الى هذه الكرفانات كحل مؤقت لحين
نقلهم الى ولايات اخرى طبعا استمرار
العيش او البقاء في هذه المدينه على ما
اظن انه مستحيل لحين اعاده اعمارها
المدينه بحاجه الى اعاده بناء احياء جديده
بالكامل لاعاده تاهيل البنى التحتيه ومن
ثم اعاده بناء المرافق العامه نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك زيدان ومراسل العربيه كان معنا
من نورداك في غازي عنتاب
اعلنت فرق الانقاذ تركيا انها تمكنت امس
من انقاذ ثمانيه اشخاص من تحت الانقاض
فيما تتلاشى الامل في العثور على المزيد
وفي كرمان مرعش مفدى العربيه
هاتفه فهل وصلت هذه الوصيه فالمتابعه لا
اله الا الله الوصيه الاخيره ظنا منه انه
مفارق يا رب انا اسف على كل شيء
[موسيقى]
في هذا الفيديو عيش حياتك ابيه خالي امير
لا تموت خليك عايش
في حياتكم صلوا صلوا صلوا تلك الوصيه لم
تصل لا للاب ولا الاخ ولا الاخرين
نجا احمد وبقيت وصيته معلقه مات من يحبهم
وفي ذاكرته صور كثيره لكن بالبيت صار
الزلزال اول حاولنا نجتمع عند الباب
ونفتحه لكن ما فتح اجز الزلزال تاني وانا
الحمد لله رب العالمين فضل رب العالمين
احسنت اطلع لفوق الانقاذ ساعدني توفى لي
عشر اشخاص ونحن حاليا بتركيا 15 بابي انه
خمسه عشر بعشر عشر ساعات قضاها احمد تحت
الانقاض وعشره ماتوا من اهله واقاربه ذاك
جرح مفتوح وتلك مصيبه يداويها الصبر
ومفاتيح فرج كهذا الرجل استقبل احمد في
بيته مع خاله بستعمل حيا الله انسان مو بس
انا كل انسان مو متضرر بيته لازم يستقبل
كل انسان منضرب معلش انا
صعب بس اني اصعب
تتعقدوا الحياه في وجه هؤلاء ويمتد الوجع
على امتداد عشر ولايات تدخل الكارثه
اسبوعها الثاني وما زالت البلاد تحصي
عشرات الالاف من قتلاها وجرحاها غسان ابو
اللوز العربيه كهرمان مرعش
انطلقت شحنه مساعده سعوديه من مطار الملك
خالد الدولي في الرياض الى مطار حلب
لاغاثه منكوب الزلزال وسيتم تسليمها الى
الهلال الاحمر السوري
هذه هي صوره خاصه للعربيه
لاستعداد طائره الاولى من الجسر الجوي
السعودي وهي طائره الاولى بالنسبه
المغادره من مطار الملك خالد الدولي الى
مطار حلب طبعا وتحمل على متنها اكثر من 32
طن من المواد الاغاثيه والمستلزمات الطبيه
وكذلك خيام وبطانيات رئيس فريق الجهود
المشتركه الاستاذ فالح بن دهيمان تحدث
للعربيه وهو رئيس فريق الجهود المشتركه
المتدربي الزلزال تحدث ان التنسيق بالنسبه
لهذه الرحله جاءت بعد تنسيق مع الجهات
المعنيه الانسانيه داخل سوريا نلتقط هذه
الصوره للان التي تقلع فيها الطائره
الاولى المتجهه من مطار الملك خالد الدولي
الى مطار حلب وهي الطائره الثامنه بالنسبه
للجسر الجوي السعودي
لغاثه متضررين الزلزال طبعا نعود مره اخرى
الاحتياجات التي تحدث بها رئيس فريق
الجهود المشتركه الاستاذ فالح بن دهيمان
والتي استقبلتها السعوديه بالنسبه بعد رفع
احتياجات من قبل الجهات المعنيه الانسانيه
داخل سوريا مثل حليب الاطفال
والمستلزمات الطبيه وايضا بعض الاحتياجات
للاحفاظ على الدم من مثل ثلاجات لبنك الدم
وبعض الاجهزه الكهربائيه طبعا يتم كنا
نسال الرئيس الفريق الجهود المشتركه كيف
سوف يتم توزيع هذه
الاغاثه على المتضررين وهل سوف تشمل كافه
المناطق المتضرره ام هناك مناطق معينه
تحدثها ان هناك تنسيق مع جهات معنيه
للهلال الاحمر السوري وسوف يتم
هذه الاغاثه على كافه المناطق او
المتضررين من جراء هذا الزلزال ايضا تحدث
للعربيه ان هناك طائرتين سوف تقنعان في
اليومين القادمين الثانيه قد تكون في نفس
في نفس هذا التوقيت من يوم غد
والثالثه سوف يتبعها
بيوم اضافه الى ان ايضا الجسر الجوي مستمر
متى ما رفعت الجهات المعنيه الانسانيه
داخل سوريا الاحتياجات التي يحتاجها
المتضرر من جراء هذه الزلزال
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
السلطات التونسيه تعتقل المعارض والقيادي
بالنهضه نور الدين البحيري
اهلا بكم من جديد اعترفت اوكرانيا بوضع
معقد شمال بخماط مركز المعارك في شرق
البلاد حيث اعلن الجيش الروسي الاستيلاء
على بلده جديده في محاوله لتطويق المدينه
في مقاله لمين العام لحلم في شمال الاطلسي
يعني انه هجوما كان مرتقبا منذ وقت طويل
للقوات الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا بدا بالفعل
واضاف روسيا تنشر بالفعل المزيد من القوات
وتتكبد خسائر كبيره لكنها تضغط على
الاوكرانيين واشار الى انما ينقص روسيا هو
الجوده لذلك تحاول تعويض هذا النقص في
الكميه وشدد سولنبرغ على اهميه توقيت
معتبرا ان الامر الملح هو تزويد اوكرانيا
سريعا بالمزيد من الاسلحه قبل ان تستطيع
روسيا امتلاك زمام المبادره في ميدان
القتال
وفيما يناقش حلف الاطلسي خلال اجتماع
تقوده الولايات المتحده لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالعتاد والتدريب بحث القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه فالوري زولوجي مع
القائد العام لقوه حلف شمال الاطلسي
المشتركه في اوروبا الجنرال الامريكي
كريستوفر كافولي مساله
العسكريه وتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه على
اراضي الدول الشركه
زار رئيس البولنديه دوده قاعده عسكريه
يجري فيها تدريب الجنود الاوكرانيين على
استخدام دبابات
وتستمر التدريبات لشهر يتعلم خلاله الجنود
الاوكرانيون استخدام هذه الدبابات عبر
اجهزه محاكاه قبل الانتقال الى التدريب
على دبابات
[تصفيق]
وثائق من وزاره الدفاع سقطت في ايدي صحفي
اوكرانيا حول عقود خاصه بامدادات الجيش من
المواد الغذائيه بلغت اسعارها ثلاثه اضعاف
المنتجات في متاجر تحقيق قاد الى كشف فساد
نطاح بمسؤولين في الوزاره بالتزامن مع
حربه الشرسه للدفاع عن مساحات شاسعه في
شرق البلاد يخوض الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
حربا موازيه ضد الفساد الذي يتغذى بحسب
مراقبين من قانون الاحوال العرفيه الذي
عطل النظم والقوانين واباح للمسؤولين
التصرف في الاموال دون رقابه مسبقه وسط
اقرب الدوائر الحكوميه وهو فريق الرئيس
نفسه الصحفيه الاوكراني يوريني
وتلقى ريشا نظيره تسهيله توريد المولدات
باسعار مضخمه فضلا عن استقاله نائب المدعي
العام اليكسيس الذي كان يقضي اجازه خارج
البلاد بينما تقصف الطائرات المسيره
العاصمه فضائح الفساد التي هزت حكومه
الحرب واشاعه الخوف من تداعي الجبهه
الداخليه احدثت غضبا كبيرا وسط الشارع
الاوكراني
هذا هو مربط الفرس اذا كانت ستكون هناك
احكام عادله فهذا امر ايجابي لسمعه
اوكرانيا
لا اعتقد ان ما يقومون به كافي بل يجب
القضاء على هؤلاء الفاسدين بسرعه
شيء مؤسف ما يحدث عندنا خاصه الان في وقت
الحرب ولكن من الجيد ان هناك رده فعل من
الرئيس حرب زيليسكي على الفساد تستهدف من
ناحيه تهدئه المجتمع الذي يشعر بالغضب من
حقيقه الحياه المترفه للمسؤولين على حساب
المحنه التي يعيشونها ومن ناحيه اخرى يظهر
زيلينسكي للحلفاء الغربيين ان مكافحه
الفساد لا تتوقف حتى اثناء الحرب خاصه مع
تعالي الاصوات في الغرب حول الحاجه الى
تدقيق انفاق الاموال المخصصه لكيف حذيفه
العربيه كيف
اعلنت وزاره دفاع الهولنديه انا مقاتلتين
هولنديتين من طراز اف 35
اعترضت تشكيلا من ثلاث طائرات عسكريه
روسيه فوق بولندا واصطحبتهما قرب منطقه
طيران النيتو في منطقه منطقه
كالينينجراد واكدت الوزاره في بيانها انها
قامت بتنشيط نظام الرد السريع الهولندي
كيو ار اي في بولندا مشيره الى ان التشكيل
الروسي تكون من مقاتله من طراز
اليوشن
العشرين ام برفقه يا طائرتان من طراز خوي
سو 28
شاركت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه نتائج
فحصها للاسلحه الايرانيه والتي ضبطتها على
متن زوارق ايرانيه في المياه الدوليه جنوب
ايران شهري يناير وفبراير من العام الماضي
شاركتها مع فريق الخبراء الاممي المعني
باليمن وجاءت هذه الخطوه قبيل اصدار
الفريق الاممي تقريره سنوي بما يتعلق بحظر
الاسلحه المفرود على اليمن
قالت المحاميه حنان
الخميري ان قوه الشرطه التونسيه اعتقلت
نور الدين البحيري القياديه البارز بحزب
حركه النهضه واضافت الخماري ان قوات
الشرطه التونسيه اعتدت بعنف شديد على زوجه
وابناء البحيري خلال عمليه اعتقاله ولم
تكشف عن اي تفاصيل اضافيه
الى العناوين
ترقب دولي لفتح معبرين لادخال المساعده
الى سوريا وفرنسا تهدد بقرار من مجلس
الامن اذا لم يلتزم النظام
تلاشي فرص العثور على ناجين والجهود تتركز
على الايواء ومساعده المتضررين من الزلزال
كيف تعترف بصعوبه او كياب عفوا تعترف
بصعوبه الوضع في بخمه وحلف الاطلسي يبحث
اليوم زياده المساعدات والتدريب للجيش
الاوكراني
نعود ونلقاكم بعد دقائق
معدودات مشاهدينا في نشره اخرى الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]